who is the holy spirit
that's a very good point on which to
begin the spirit
is a member of the heavenly trio we have
father
son and holy ghost at the baptism of
jesus
in matthew 3 verse 16
we have christ coming out of the water
we have the father speaking from above
and we have the spirit in the form of a
dove sitting on the shoulder of jesus
in the great gospel commission matthew
28 19 baptized them in the name of the
father
and of the son and of the holy spirit in
first john 5
7 we have the father the son and the
holy spirit there are three that bear
record in heaven
the spirit is the first member of the
godhead mentioned in the bible by name
genesis 1 verse 1 and 2 in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
first too
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep and the spirit of god
moved upon the face of the waters the
spirit
is one member of the heavenly trio and
as ella white writes in evangelism page
615 paragraph one
there are three living members of the
heavenly trio
the father the son and the holy ghost
and in their name
not their names their name because they
all have the same name the same
character
the same mind the same purpose in their
name
people are baptized and by their
strength and their power
the believers are able to live the new
life and so this holy spirit
is a member of the trinity